it is April 17 2023 and you are watching
the code report yo check out this new
Drake track featuring The Weekend that
just dropped
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty hot but it's actually all AI
generated it was made by this mysterious
Ghost Rider 977 account on Tick Tock
which we'll investigate in just a minute
the song itself already has millions of
plays but it's not the only AI track
going viral we've also got Kanye singing
Justin Bieber's love yourself
[Music]
oh baby you should go and love yourself
that sounds almost Flawless but these
are some of the best cherry-picked
examples like when you try to have
Michael Jackson sing an Eminem song
you'll notice a lot more artifacts than
the end result
if you want to learn how to do stuff
like this yourself I'd recommend
watching this video from Roberto Nixon
unlike myself he has some decent rapping
skills but I spit a few bars anyway and
here's the Masterpiece I got back yo
it's easy in the house about to spit
some truth about a channel on YouTube
it's called fire no spoof
Innovative is Tesla shining like Edison
teaching Tech with style code that got
bad adrenaline and of course Chachi BT
wrote the actual rap for me what's most
interesting though is what this might do
to the music industry in the future back
in the 90s when Napster came out it was
like the greatest thing ever for a while
because you could quote unquote share
music with your friends without needing
to go to the record store and pay twenty
dollars for a CD but eventually the
music industry realized this thing was
going to cut into its profits so the
Master of Puppets got Metallica to make
Napster Fade to Black by suing it for
copyright infringement and racketeering
it's sad but true but the Memory Remains
but AI music is even more Insidious
because it's not just like taking one
song it hijacks an entire artist's
ability to create being born with Talent
no longer matters we can just use
technology to steal your talent and
remix it in an infinite number of ways
but on the plus side if you die you are
Talent can live on forever like have you
guys heard Kurt Cobain singing this new
Nirvana song drowned in the Sun
[Music]
I think it's only a matter of time
before they crack down on this
technology once Lars for Metallica hears
about this it's going to be over quickly
and we'll have to start trading these AI
tracks on the dark web right now there's
some innocent naive kid out there who's
going to use AI to generate a Taylor
Swift song in a couple of years
I open up only to have the FBI breaking
his door shoot his dog and put him in
jail for 20 years but now let's get back
to this viral Drake track some have
speculated that it's not even AI
generated and in fact it was Drake All
Along under this bed sheet that's
possible but this tick tocker is also
harvesting emails with an app called
laylo which is a y combinator company
that does big drops with creators
designed to go viral if you don't know
why combinator is a startup accelerator
that used to be run by Sam oltman the
current CEO of openai I'm not sure what
it is yet but something seems fishy here
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one